[Música]
al menos cinco personas fallecieron en
colombia según las autoridades en una
noche de disturbios y protestas contra
la brutalidad policial la muerte del
abogado javier ordóñez esta semana tras
someterlo violentamente en la vía
pública llevó a cientos de personas a la
calle y quemaron al menos 45 estaciones
de policía
en eeuu el presidente de donald trump
reconoció que minimizó la gravedad de la
pandemia en sus inicios el mandatario
argumentó que intentaba evitar el pánico
sus declaraciones llegaron tras la
publicación de una entrevista de febrero
en la que habló de los peligros del cob
y 19
y los siete países europeos que rodean
el mar mediterráneo se reúnen en córcega
para la cumbre de siete el tema
principal es la disputa entre grecia y
turquía por la explotación energética en
aguas que comparten sus fronteras la
crisis de libia y los incendios en el
campamento de refugiados de moria
también hacen parte de la agenda
comienza la mañana y también las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez iniciamos el informativo en
américa latina' colombia vivió una noche
de disturbios y enfrentamientos de la
ciudadanía contra la policía por la
muerte del abogado javier ordóñez tras
ser brutalmente sometido por oficiales
cinco personas fallecieron como
consecuencia de las movilizaciones
violentas en varias ciudades que también
dejaron al menos 45 estaciones de
policía en llamas los hechos han
reavivado el debate sobre los abusos
policiales en el país los agentes
implicados o fueron suspendidos y están
siendo investigados marina sardenya
tiene más información
por favor nomás me ahogo fue el grito de
auxilio del abogado javier ordóñez
cuando dos agentes de la policía de
bogotá lo redujeron en el suelo y les
sometieron a incesantes descargas
eléctricas
con un arma tipo taser durante más de
dos minutos fue trasladado a una unidad
policial y posteriormente a un centro
hospitalario donde murió sede falleció
además estaba alicoramiento que estaba
alterado que agredió a la policía que ya
había sido controlado y que lo único que
estaba pidiendo la que no lo agredieran
más que no lo atacaran más con eso te
hice le siguen y le siguen y le siguen
metiendo esa tracer y además se lo
llevan a un cádiz no hay una explicación
clara y el ciudadano termina falleciendo
en un hospital de bogotá
eso es inaceptable los hechos ocurrieron
durante la madrugada del miércoles según
testigos el abogado padre de dos menores
replicó las autoridades cuando éstas le
impusieron un comparendo por la ingesta
de alcohol prohibido en el marco de la
pandemia la respuesta policial fue
aplicar la fuerza y el vídeo grabado por
los presentes rápidamente se viralizó
las imágenes desencadenaron oleada de
protestas en las calles de la capital y
se replicaron en otras ciudades del país
el ministro de defensa prometió justicia
en el caso concreto de los graves hechos
ocurridos en el barrio santa cecilia los
dos agentes son ya objeto de
investigación disciplinario y penal y la
institución dará toda la colaboración
que refiere a la autoridad competente el
caso de ordóñez quedó en manos de la
justicia penal militar una noche de
manifestaciones y conmoción pues las
imágenes de la muerte del colombiano
recuerdan a las de georges floyd
afroamericano que murió en eeuu luego de
que un agente apoyara su rodilla contra
su cuello por casi nueve minutos y por
las que se desataron masivas
movilizaciones sociales en todo el mundo
contra la violencia policial
en noticias de la pandemia en eeuu
donald trump alegó que estaba tratando
de evitar el pánico al negar la gravedad
del cob y 19 en su defensa tras la
polémica por hacerse públicos los audios
de una entrevista que le hizo el
veterano periodista de investigación bob
woodward en el mes de febrero en los
audios de hombre conoce la peligrosidad
del nuevo virus que él mismo minimizó al
comienzo
mintió deliberadamente donald trump al
pueblo de eeuu durante los primeros
meses de la pandemia el mandatario
minimizó públicamente y en repetidas
ocasiones los peligros del cob y 19
me gustaría pediría advertir a los
medios de comunicación ya todos los
demás involucrados que no haga nada para
incitar al pánico porque no hay razón
para entrar en pánico en absoluto pero
según revelan los audios de las
entrevistas realizadas en ese periodo
por el periodista bob woodward para su
nuevo libro reich el mandatario si sabía
de la gravedad del nuevo coronavirus
siempre he querido restarle importancia
es muy complicado
es muy delicado e incluso más mortífero
que la gripe común
un discurso radicalmente opuesto al que
trump transmitía la opinión pública se
irá solo mantengan la calma asegura ante
la nueva polémica y cuando eeuu roza los
190 mil decesos por coronavirus trump se
ha retractado de sus declaraciones
pasadas alegando que intentaba contener
el pánico y la histeria colectiva bueno
creo que si dijera que para reducir el
pánico tal vez
soy un admirador de este país amo
nuestro país y no quiero que la gente se
asuste desde la oposición su rival en la
carrera por la casa blanca el demócrata
joe biden le acusa de mentir al pueblo
estadounidense y él tenía la información
sabía lo peligroso que era y mientras
esta enfermedad mortal arrasaba nuestra
nación no hizo su trabajo a propósito
fue una traición de vida o muerte para
el pueblo estadounidense no fue hasta
julio que el republicano cambió su
discurso y comenzó a usar mascarillas en
público un giro de 180 grados
incentivado por las encuestas que
muestran que dos tercios de los
estadounidenses desaprueban su gestión
de la pandemia de cara a las elecciones
y en el mundo ya se registra en 27 8
millones de contagios de kobe 19 los
fallecidos son 900 4000 y los
recuperados 18,7 millones en europa el
rebrote de la enfermedad se propaga
masivamente españa reportó 4.400
contagios en la última jornada y ya
sobrepasa 543 mil infecciones en francia
fueron 8500 nuevos positivos para un
consolidado de más de 380.000 entre
tanto reino unido quiere evitar a toda
costa una segunda ola y emitió la regla
de seis que prohíbe reuniones que
superen ese número de personas alemania
anunció que desde el 30 de septiembre
levanta la recomendación general contra
viajes no esenciales a zonas de riesgo
incluyendo españa y la sustituirá por
advertencias por países o regiones
italia reabre colegios este 14 de
septiembre
la cumbre del mediterráneo med 7 se
realiza hoy en córcega con el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón como anfitriona
el encuentro tiene lugar cada año desde
2016 y reúne países europeos alrededor
del mediterráneo' para tratar sus
problemas colectivos entre los temas
están la crisis de libia y la nueva
crisis de migrantes desatada por los
incendios en el campamento de memoria en
lesbos que dejaron a la intemperie a
miles de los 13.000 refugiados que
alberga pero el asunto más urgente es la
atención actual entre grecia y turquía
enfrascados en una disputa de mar
territorial rico en gas y petróleo
el presidente macro no ofreció ya sus
primeras declaraciones
y yo hablo de un pacto mediterráneo que
debe encontrar un acuerdo con turquía
pero nosotros debemos nosotros los
europeos ser claros y firmes no con
turquía como nación como pueblo sino con
el gobierno del presidente erdogán que
hoy tiene un comportamiento inadmisible
y compacto en el municipio algunas
poblaciones de vida silvestre se
desplomaron dos tercios en el mundo
desde 1970 eso concluyó el informe
planeta vivo 2020 de la organización
ecologista wwf explicaron que la
conversión de tierras para la
agricultura y el comercio de vida
silvestre fueron las razones clave de la
caída promedio de 68 por ciento en miles
de grupos de mamíferos aves anfibios
reptiles y peces entre en 1970 y 2016
y la película moulin que se empezó a
distribuir desde la semana pasada
enfrenta demandas de boicot después de
que se conociera que algunas escenas se
rodaron en xinjiang una región china
donde se han registrado abusos contra la
población musulmana veamos
mullan la nueva película de acción de
disney que protagoniza una guerrera que
se hizo leyenda gracias a largometraje
de animación de 1998 ha despertado
malestar por parte de algunos
espectadores no por su contenido sino
por el lugar en donde se rodó disney
incluye agradecimientos especiales a 8
entidades del gobierno de changjiang una
provincia en donde grupos defensores de
los derechos humanos han denunciado una
fuerte represión contra los musulmanes
uigures entre los abusos expuestos
figuran detenciones masivas
esterilizaciones y trabajos forzados
también se agradece el departamento de
propaganda del partido comunista chino
la película moulin es vista como un
intento de china de mejorar su imagen
mientras varios periodistas y activistas
piden su boicot en 1946 disney publicó
la canción del sur en donde se glorifica
la vida en una plantación en términos
dolorosamente racistas acertadamente
avergonzados disney más tarde retiró la
película ahora es difícil encontrar una
copia se puede decir que moulin es su
película más problemática desde entonces
no por su contenido sino por los
bochornosos compromisos hechos por
disney
poder rodarla por qué deberíamos
boicotear moulin se trata de hipocresía
en las películas de hollywood aseguran
adoptar la justicia social en realidad
se postran ante la china autocrática
vergonzosamente se avergüenzan ellos
mismos defendiendo valores en los que no
cree en las películas deberían ser algo
más que dinero el presupuesto de 200
millones de dólares ya es inmerso en una
polémica después de que la protagonista
del ife y respaldar a la publicidad de
hong kong en su represión contra los
manifestantes prodemocracia el año
pasado
disney de momento no se ha pronunciado
siga con nosotros
[Música]